atout
[Musique]
chris qu'est-ce que l'enfer
emmenez-le
dans la vie et dans la mort nous rendons
gloire la cloche sonne pour nous tous
ils reviennent
[Musique]
arrête d'être si paranoïaque
il y a longtemps une jeune fille est partie avec  sa
mère pour cueillir des baies pour son père
qui travaillait dur mais la forêt les a
accueillis avec un silence sombre et
froid les buissons vides
mais déterminés à trouver les baies le
coquin s'est libéré de l'emprise de sa mère
et a disparu dans les
arbres  la
fille a couru sur
la vigne sous la branche
et dans la forêt profonde
[Applaudissements]
c'est juste un conte local
[Musique]
si c'est juste regarder les vitrines